what do you mean tip your bag handler at
the airport
[ __ ] one day you know give him a 20 tip
on his salary to get your bag delivered
we [ __ ] talk about that because
that's that's one frustration i've had
since getting here right so it's like
you know obviously because we had lost
our [ __ ] right and it still hasn't been
resolved we've got to figure out ways to
get the equipment right so it's like
we're calling up camera plate camera
rental places we're calling up light
rental places yeah all that kind of
stuff and then we realized oh there's no
uh mic stands right because we're
usually attached to a table right but
wait like that's not going to work with
you know the current set we're in right
now so we're like all right [ __ ] we got
to buy some mic stands so i'm like all
right i'll just get some on amazon you
know go on to amazon blah blah blah
and i think again this is where we're
blessed with amazon japan standards yeah
which is it is very rare to get
something on amazon no matter how small
or large how cheap or expensive it is
and usually 99 times out of 100 you'll
get it the next day yeah delivery next
day delivery that's just like normal
yeah
so i thought
it would be the same here yeah they do
have next day delivery
if you would like to pay
500 more for shipping yeah and like i
looked at it and i was like hold on how
does that work so i get free shipping if
it comes on
like three days from now yeah but if i
want it tomorrow
i basically have to tip amazon
10 15 more yeah to get it the next day
yeah it's about 10 15 delivery uh if you
want to get your stuff the next day yeah
which i'm i'm of we're obviously blessed
with amazon uk amazon japan which it
comes free with prime you get next day
delivery yeah and like you know i like i
would i would understand maybe if uh if
it was kind of like
one thing that surprised me because i
thought you know [ __ ] amazon started
in california right yeah yeah yeah so so
can we fact check that at least because
amazon yeah
it's uh seattle is this yeah oh yeah
okay okay
it's american yeah okay okay okay just
fine ignore that
that's
but i would think that
with la being one of the
the [ __ ] major cities in america
right because like you get perks if you
order from say london in the uk i
thought with la with this being like you
know hollywood and needing a lot of
equipment a lot of shipment and
everything like that i thought that they
would have a service that is more
convenient um and i yeah i was very
surprised to see that you can't get the
same level of convenience
uh just by being in l.a you literally
have to pay to win yeah it's it's hard
right there's a lot of like uh
socio-economic factors involved right
yeah i mean already right like
next day shipping you don't really need
next day shipping like when do you how
often do you need next day shipping all
the time no never normally no i do
because i i usually when i have to buy
something on amazon it's when i need it
urgently yeah and i don't have enough
time to go to the shops to get it or i
or perhaps it's something that i can't
get like an example just give me an
example
well say for example like camera
equipment in japan right
it's very rare that you can go to a big
enough like yoda bash your big camera
that has the exact specifics
or you know sometimes there are some
brands for example that you can't easily
access in japanese but like i i'd say
it's very rare that you need 100 you
need this next day like i bet 90 of [ __ ]
you ordered amazon you did you did not
need that next day well i'm sure yeah
but the convenience is there right yeah
yeah it's there i think it's it's good
to have that convenience but i think
especially in america because it's just
like so inefficient
and like you know everything is
delivered by roads like have you seen
the videos of like the
the freight trains at the liver stuff in
like california yeah yeah i have to
[ __ ] break it open yeah yeah they get
robbed all the [ __ ] time wow i just
think because the infrastructure just
isn't there and then
the next day delivery that they do do is
almost like
it like [ __ ] up the like the people who
have to actually deliver it because they
have to do these insane routes right
deliver this and they're pissing in
bottles and [ __ ] yeah so a part of me is
like yeah i'd love next day delivery but
i feel like just in america it just
doesn't it's not feasible it's not
feasible and if you are doing it
something bad is happening to someone
who is yeah i guess this is definitely
like me being privileged it's
definitely pretty much i just wanted to
talk about it because i'm like it's a
complicated thing and like
yeah
i mean there's a bigger underlying issue
to it you know japan the for some reason
people don't give a [ __ ] about being
worked like crazy for like nine hours
and being super efficient i don't know
why in the uk you get next day delivery
as well you do but in london it's it
seems like it's it would make way more
sense to have that work in london but
like in wales you don't have that oh you
don't
no not really like i live right next to
the amazon warehouse in swansea and it
was never next day delivery really i
lived next to the warehouse right for
the whole area
uh it's just i don't know london it
makes more sense it's possible there's a
lot more like carriers is there maybe
like a sense of urgency towards like
fulfilling customer like requests maybe
because like i i assume in wales not a
lot of people are like ordering from
amazon right sure
surely in cardiff right maybe in
carthage yeah yeah but like i think all
the card afforders are being filled
fulfilled by the swansea yeah yeah yeah
it's about an hour yeah because like i
guess that's what i thought where i
would understand if you lived like in
the [ __ ] boonies like in the middle
of nowhere okay you're not gonna get to
get next day delivery right but like if
you live in america this is l.a yeah
this is this is l.a you can get it but
like i it's only certain items right
because it's got to be fulfilled by
amazon which means it's in their
warehouse already and then they get one
of their couriers to come and get it and
that makes more sense but i don't know
the whole [ __ ] system here is weird
and even in europe it's like not as good
as japan japan works just but japan's
had like like an amazing shipping
network for like forever yeah like
they've they've they've just got to
figure it out yeah yeah everything like
that's what they care about yeah that's
like their like and not a single tip was
necessary yeah because
because people here they're like bro
we've got like so many issues like guns
and then japan's like yeah that if the
[ __ ] package doesn't [ __ ] turn up
when i tell it to i'm not voting for you
yeah like that's like legit that's what
they give a [ __ ] about it we've only
been here like a few days and like
within that few days we've just like we
can feel like an entire complaining
about america like like this is just the
complaining about america episode
yeah yeah because it's just this endless
[ __ ] stream because like i think it's
like an endless loop of like dichotomy
is like okay oh this big company does
bad thing but it's like the reason why
it's doing bad thing is because people
don't want to do anything else and yeah
it's just [ __ ] up
because like i i get it to a point why
why i've experienced such bad customer
service because it's because
they have no [ __ ] incentive to give a
[ __ ] about their job right and you know
i get it you know i've i've especially
dealing with people at the airport you
deal with like the most stressed out
people in the world right you know at
you know at a level i get it you know
um and it's kind of sad in a way where i
see a lot of people in customer service
uh positions and you and it feels like
the only people that you see actually
care about giving a good service is when
there is an option to tip in the
occupation yeah right
it's true yeah i mean i mean that's
that's that's just what i've seen like
if like there is there are plenty of
customer service positions in america
but only the ones that tip i've
with my own experience is the ones where
you really feel that they care about the
customer right right and
ah society right
we live in a society society i i'd love
to say that man yeah dude i would do
different yeah i would totally care yeah
i don't think i'd care no no no well no
no i'd be like i don't [ __ ] care like
why would i
you know it's on my back well especially
if you're surrounded by that environment
right it's like you'd look like the
weirdo if you're the one that's caring
i'm i'm sure at lax that woman has
probably had the most horrible people
like yeah shouting at her yeah and just
screaming and then no repercussions yeah
yeah yeah
the guy [ __ ] walks off goes home he's
like oh there's nothing wrong yeah you
know you know yeah yeah yeah i i totally
get that it's it sucks though but it
does suck she's like why don't me i was
nice to you yeah yeah yeah but like it
sucks for me because like i happen to be
the person that all that [ __ ]
frustration got taken out of yeah you
know
like it just felt [ __ ] horrible just
not to be given the time of day or just
to be like made to feel guilty for just
trying to like resolve one issue in my
end even in the uk that's pretty rare
yeah they happen often the i feel like
there's a level of disappointment and
resentment that everyone has
it doesn't
because i feel like in the uk you can
really just like look i'm going through
a [ __ ] day right now you know like
you you there's a certain tone where you
know especially in this kind of
situations where i feel like it's much
rarer in the uk from what i've seen to
like see people really have like a
[ __ ] outburst you know what i mean i
mean that they were they're all planning
i've seen playing it will definitely
happen but it's less than what i've seen
you know here in america at least okay i
just i just needed to vent a bit okay
because i literally like lost about like
encountering about like eight hours of
my time to this i mean like when it's
when it's lax it's like triple like yeah
yeah yeah you you gave eight but you
lost 20 times yeah yeah i move slowly i
feel like i lost like a year of my life
with this with this experience you know
i mean i'd be miserable if i worked at
lax yeah it's [ __ ] [ __ ] worst
airport i'm miserable going through lax
let alone working out people people are
like bro at least we're not in newark
i'm like you're not [ __ ] any better
like what are you on about like you all
suck it's all this is all broken none of
this works
yeah so actually because like this like
because we've been to la before but i
think this is like the first time we've
had like extended stay in l.a right yeah
the longest time i've been in la like in
one goes maybe like five days yeah at
most yeah and that's always been in
downtown right and every time i talk to
a local they're like
downtown really yeah that's like that's
that's like that's like the awful it's
pretty scary yeah that's the sketch
sector like
you'll get stabbed or shot uh if you
walk down the streets there which is
something we've definitely come close to
experiencing uh in downtown l.a around
ax but like the reason we normally come
to la is because of ax and ax is in
downtown l.a so
um so this is actually our first like
experience mostly like outside of
downtown but also getting a chance to
like you know experience actually
explore los angeles yeah yeah so you
guys were like here a few days before me
how was how was your guys's experience
well it was good until i got covered
that's true
i mean it was good for like the first
three or four days because i was staying
in pasadena yeah which is like a
relatively nicer part of l.a
everyone in la says it's a nice part of
l.a it was nice to be fair yeah um and
then you have like you know places like
glendale which is next door which is
where all the youtubers live yeah um and
stuff and like i definitely saw like a
more
like relaxed and more i guess like i
felt safer in pasadena and glendale
right a million times more than in
downtown l.a yeah which is not hard
because downtown la is just gta in real
life right so it's like you know i felt
a lot safer and i was like okay i can
actually like kind of walk the streets
of pasadena during the day yeah and it
feels just like a regular town it's like
kind of nice and there's like lots of
places to eat and it's like really chill
yeah um like drake and josh when i
realized that yeah
i felt like i was on an episode of drake
and josh a little bit yeah i like walked
past like at like an elementary school
that looked like
like it was ripped straight from the
simpsons and i was like oh
like it was like that was like okay you
know
it was that point where i'm just like
okay you know what la why not b is bad
yeah and then again there was just those
like just small little instances
that just made me be like
yeah maybe not maybe right
yeah like say the [ __ ] lax situation
yeah like you know the amazon situation
it's just like it's it's very nitpicky i
know yeah but i think it just goes to
show how much we've been blessed in
tokyo i mean like it's it's nitpicky but
it's like it's when you choose for like
a place to live for example like place
visiting and living is like two totally
different experiences but like it's it's
a lot of like little things that will
build up over time of course you know
and it's you know one thing i've really
really missed
is walking yeah i've missed walking a
lot and you know i'm sure like there are
some places in la which i'm you know i'm
sure you can walk you know but like i
feel like a lot of america as a whole is
just not built for walking yeah that's
all right because i remember i was i was
meeting up with a friend of mine uh and
she she just lives she lives like kind
of uh in the middle between pasadena and
glendale so like from my hotel it was
like
20 minute walk yeah right at most yeah
and so i was like we were hanging in
pasadena we had lunch and [ __ ] and then
i was like oh let's just go back to your
place and we'll just hang out yeah and i
looked on the map and it was like 20
minutes so i'm like yeah we can walk
that it's a nice day [ __ ] it's the
middle of the day it's like what 2pm
yeah afternoon i kind of want to have a
walk and she was like she looked at me
like i was a [ __ ] weirdo she was like
what are you homeless yeah it's just
like walking what the [ __ ] this is like
we're gonna walk it and i'm like
don't [ __ ] look at me like that like
yes i would like to use my legs because
i haven't done that in a while since i
got here
and uh and she was just like
okay
and you know kind of thing and she kind
of reluctantly followed me yeah um i got
like five minutes into this walk yeah
and i turned a corner and i was like i
don't want to go down there
i was like okay i can see what you were
talking about
yes it's a 20 minute walk but it's also
20 minutes of my life potentially in a
lot of danger at the same time you know
it's 30 minutes when you've got to do
like the navy seals checks and all that
yeah yeah yeah
when you've got to dodge all the
homeless people yeah but it's uh yeah i
don't know even
but like i felt i feel weird catching an
uber to some place that's like five
minutes away yeah but it's you have to
right living here and i think that's
like one thing that made me realize
you know perhaps
la is fun to visit but definitely i
wouldn't want to live here yeah
personally speaking i don't know when
there's like four lanes of like cars
it's like crossing it just feels like a
[ __ ] dice roll
and there's like a lot of them don't
have light so i'm like wait so when do i
go it's just like no no you play chicken
you cross the first two yeah and then
you kind of wait in the middle literally
the moment you step out of the car you
are playing with your life
you're just playing frogger
yeah i mean it gets pretty [ __ ] scary
especially like especially when you're
in downtown l.a or like any like sketch
places right which there are a number of
in l.a no no i'm white
yeah you get a free pass
[Music]
because i [ __ ] i still remember i was
saying this to conor the other day i
still remember that [ __ ] airbnb you
and sydney booked at the last time we
were in uh ax oh yeah and i remember you
sent me you were having like a house
party and you sent me the the address
right on google maps and i was like oh
sick it's like literally just around the
corner from our hotel so i was just like
let's just [ __ ] walk it's a three
minute walk right and i remember we were
mostly on the main road you know cars
whizzing by you know a couple of people
on the streets or whatever it's like all
right cool yeah and the moment we got to
your street it was just this dark
alleyway
yeah and i'm like this can't be right
yeah and then from all the way across
the alleyway i could just hear you going
over here
and i'm like you are not making me walk
down the stairs
are you kidding me yeah there are like
two other people in this alleyway look
and sketch as [ __ ] just like standing
around like i'm literally about to put
my life on the line yeah to go and hang
out with god yeah all right [ __ ] it
let's do it because it was like i
remember that airbnb because inside it
looked [ __ ] fantastic you know this
side was great yeah it was [ __ ]
fantastic we had like a pool table
everything like it was it was a nice
open space yeah but my god it was in
like the most sketch area you could ever
imagine and i felt bad whenever like i
was inviting people around to that
airbnb because you remember you like
yeah at least like you walked down that
dark alleyway because like our house is
like right at the end of this dark
alleyway and it wasn't it was like an
alleyway with a dead end so
like if you would like to rank like the
top places to get mugged in la are like
i'm pretty sure that was like top 10
places to get mugged and stabbed in l.a
and i remember like
uh i invited super eye patch wolf john
uh to the apartment as well and i
remember he gets the same point right
and and all i see is like a dark
silhouette because he's like he's saying
that he's standing at the end of this
alleyway i see like this dark silhouette
it's john he's by himself and
uh and i'm like i go out i see him like
god oh yeah oh yeah but like i'm sure to
him he just goes
and so like and so i remember he like he
sees my silhouette i remember he starts
walking the opposite direction
immediately starts like power walking
the opposite direction
yeah yeah yeah and so i have to like
[ __ ] sprint to run up to him do we go
john john it's me it's me don't worry
and then he starts running faster
oh yeah that was scary yeah yeah yeah i
remember a long time ago connor you were
saying that you wanted to live in
america
yeah i think it'd be fun for a while has
that has that opinion changed no dude
i'd get so much content living here yeah
but you'd have to well like okay okay
when you say living in america do you
mean living in l.a i don't know about
that yeah
like i just feel like even like you just
talked to an uber driver you're like
great i just got content for like a week
dude
you're talking about this guy how crazy
[ __ ] he said to me yeah yeah it's like
it's a crazy place but it's like i don't
know at some point i'd like to
experience it more but because i feel
like even two weeks isn't enough right i
want to experience the awful process of
like signing up for a water bill or
something
why would you want to why would you why
i don't know i love that [ __ ] have you
have you not already experienced it
enough in japan no but yeah i love going
through that mundane stuff about it it's
like i don't know if you really feel
like you're in it i don't know why
something about that experience i really
enjoy yeah i'm good bro during i'm like
this is awful yeah but after the fact
i'm like like i'd love to be like yeah
lax dude what a [ __ ] crazy you know
you know what i mean
i said now i'm like [ __ ] i don't wanna
go to alex yeah yeah let's get lax it's
[ __ ] weird i mean like being here for
a few days we've already got like a
[ __ ] like week's worth of content for
trash takes yeah honestly honestly dude